وصلنا الى هذه الفقره الجميله بلحن
الموسيقى من موظف الى ملحن ومطرب بيت ثلاث
دقات فتح باب النجوميه اصبح له معجبين في
كل مكان ومن كل الاعمار بعدها اصدر عدد من
الاغنيات التي حققت شهره كبيره بما فيها
اغنيه حبيبي يا ليل التي حققت عشره ملايين
مشاهده على يوتيوب خلال 24 ساعه فقط ضيفنا
اليوم في صباح العربيه المطرب والملحن ابو
نتعرف اكثر على طريقه نشر اغانيه بفصل
الاغاني الفرديه عن البومات وهل هي سبب
نجاح اعماله اليوم ايضا سيطلق معنا اغنيته
الجديده ونتعرف اكثر مع ابوه على خططه
المستقبليه على كل اللي نورنا اليوم في
الاستوديو الفنان الجميل ابو اهلا بك
احنا اكثر كاتب وملحن ومطرب قرر يصير مغني
وحقق اعجاب الملايين حدثنا اكثر الاول قبل
اي حاجه عايز اقول لكم ازاي النهارده
العالمين وكل سنه وكل ام وزوجه واخت وبنت
بالف خير
اه انا طول عمري بحب الكتابه
والتلحين قوي الكلمه بدات الكتابه
والتلحين انه انا عندي 15 سنه بس كانت طول
عمرها اهو ودرست فرنس بالجامعه الامريكيه
في مصر وخرجت واشتغلت وبتاع وبعد كده سن
كبير شويه قلت طب ليه بيضيع وقتي في حاجه
وانا الباسورد بتاعي كله في المزيكا فسيبت
كل حاجه وعملت مزيكا ياسر ابو انا شايفه
انه النساء في المحطه من اول ما شافوه كل
وحده فيهم قلبها دقه ثلاث دق بس هل انت
اليوم بزعلك ولا بفرحك انه ارتبطت ابو
ثلاث دقاته ولدها تضل خلص يعني ملتزمه
وملاصقه لابو انت حابب انه تطلع من هذه
العنوان طبعا
يعني
بس هو في الاخر ارتضيت ان هي بالعكس يعني
بحب كده وعلى مدى التاريخ كان الواحد
هيمشي اكتر في المشوار هتروح هيبقى مش ابو
ثلاث دقات اكيد هيطلع حاجات ثانيه طيب ابو
في ناس يعني بتصدر اغنيه سنجل تنجح بعدين
يختلفون انت توقعت اغنيه بعدها تحقق عشر
ملايين مشاهده بنفس النجاح واكثر حبيبي يا
ليل اقول لك حاجه انا بالنسبه لي النجاح
او مقياس النجاح مش بتجيب قد ايه ناس نجاح
هو الاستمراريه اه حبيبي يا ليل جابت 10
ملايين في 24 ساعه
وكانت بالنسبه لي حاجه تخض برده بس عمري
في حياتي والله ما بلتفت لمين جاب كام حتى
في عز ما تلات دقات كانت
مولعه الدنيا تمام يعني انا اهم حاجه
بالنسبه لي ان انا انزل الاغاني اللي انا
عايز انزلها واكمل في الاستمراريه نجاح
مهم ولكن استمراريه هي الاهم طيب انت يا
ابو شو شعورك انه اغاني
ك وسط كوريا الجنوبيه يعني فرقه بي اي جي
الكوريه الجنوبيه وهي مشهوره كمان كتير
نشرت فيديو لاغنيه ثلاث دقات على طريقتهم
ايشعورك لكن لذيذ قوي انبسطت وخلي بالك
اتعملت كفر روسي وامريكاني يا كابتن
فدي كانت حاجه دي احلى حاجه في المزيكا
يعني حتى لو مش بيفهم لغه اللحن يوصل له
اه طيب المن فيك تختار اغاني تنزلها
سينجلز وشو سر نجاحها ليش اخترت هالطريق
تحديدا الطريقه دي انا اخترتها علشان على
عكس زمان ما حدش بقى بيسمع يعني اخر مره
انت مسكتي البوم شخص وسمعتيه كله ايه
سريع قوي عايزين نسمع ابوه بعد كده نسمع
مش عارفين بعد كده مش عارف مين فكره ان
تنزلي بقلبهم بقت قليله اوي بقت مور
ارتستك عنها كوميرشن
بس انا ان شاء الله السنه دي في الصيف ده
هنزل بقلبهم يعني اول مره لقلبه اللي انا
عايز اعمله عشان الارتستك محتاج ان انا
انزل حاجه بكونسبت بالتوفيق اكيد راح نحكي
عنه الالبوم بس كمان بتقدر تسمح لنا نسالك
ليه ابوه ده اسمي
شهره
اسمي محمد ابو العينين
وصحابي من انا عندي سبع سنين ابوه وحتى في
الشغل لما كنت شغال في الشركات برضو اسمي
ابوه يعني طول عمر الناس بتقول يعني انت
انت مغني انت انت حلوه وكمان في ليركس
باللغه الهيروغليفيه المصريه للمصريين
القدامى وحتى انه الذكاء الاصطناعي يصنف
مصر من اجمل شعوب العالم المصريات كمان بس
ازيدك يعني بهالموضوع طيب وكتابه الاغاني
ابوه بالنسبه لتجربتك مع كتابه الاغاني
بصي انا اساس الموضوع كان بالنسبه لي
الكتابه حتى يعني معظم اعمالي انا اللي
ببقى كاتبها وحتى لما بشترك مع مع كاتب
بنعمل ورشه عشان خاطر نوصل للحاله اللي
احنا عايزينها فانا بالنسبه لي الكتابه
عشق يعني وبقى في شيت اوي الكلمه اللي
بتتعمل يعني طيب ابو هل لازم يضل ابو يغني
اغاني حب ورومانسيه ممكن نشوف اتجاه ثاني
لانه في اغاني فيها حزن وانتقام
وظلام بس حلوه وبتضرب كمان انا طول عمري
الاغاني اللي كنت بكتبها كلها حاجه عن حال
الدنيا وعن حال الناس وحاجات كده طول عمري
كنت كده بدات بعد كده بدات ادخل في
الرومانسيه شويه بس اخدت وقتها الكافي
القلب ان شاء الله اللي نازل في الصيف دوت
هيبقى بعيد عن الرومانسيه شويه
اخر اغنياتك
لحد ما الحان احمد العتباني
وتوزيع رامي سمير وكتابه احمد حلمي
الاغنيه دي شغالين عليها تقريبا سنه ونص
عملنا عليها ورشه وقعدنا ظهرنا في لحن
وعملنا في الكتابه وبتاع والحمد لله نزلت
ولقت اعجاب الناس جدا يعني دايما النجاح
يحالفني في اغانيك اخراجيا انك تركز على
الاخراج تخلي الاغنيه ملفته للجمهور
ويشاركوك نجوم مصر في اغانيك او الصراحه
اول مره تعمل ده كان ثلاث دقات كانت كل
النجوم وصلوا مع مع عظيمه يا يسرا بعد كده
لما عملت عيش يا قلبي عملتها بلبنان
واستضفت فيها
الفنانه
رفيق علي احمد فدائما بحب انا امزج
الكونيف ببعض المزيكا بالتمثيل بالحاجات
طيب
ابو انت تغني باللهجه المصريه ولا ممكن
نسمعك بلهجات ثانيه
طيب مشاريعك ابوه تحدثنا قبل شوي عن قلبهم
جديد البوم جديد ان شاء الله هينزل في
الصيف
وفي في كذا دلوقتي هيبقى لذيذ قوي في
الصيف دوت بس هو حاجات كده تفض لذيذه وبس
وهفضل اكمل مزيكا وانشر سعاده الناس كلها
ابو الانسان شو
بتحب بحب بقى اي حاجه لها علاقه
بالبحرتيشن
رياضه جدا بحب ما بحبش الزحمه بحب
الخروجات اللي تبقى كلها اخرنا اربعه خمسه
فانت هادي وحياتك هاديه يعني وشغلي مش
هادي طيب
لما شاركترا الاغاني هل يمكن نشاهد ابوه
في ديو في كذا ضيوف حيحصل ان شاء الله
الفتره الجايه بعد رمضان كل سنه وانتم
طيبين
اغانيك المقبله وشكرا لوجودك كمان شكرا
شكرا